comienza el torneo de Roland garros aquí
en París y por primera vez en 19 años no
estará Rafael Nadal quien tiene una
lesión en su cadera y esto Deja las
posibilidades bastante abiertas por
primera vez en el tablero masculino
dejando posibilidades a Novak de
conseguir su título número 23 en una
Grand pero más allá del serbio Está
también Carlos Alcaraz uno de los más
serios pretendientes a Este título
solamente 20 años y a pesar de haber
tenido un gran comienzo de temporada un
poco difícil ha ganado seis torneos en
los que ha participado como Barcelona y
Madrid a pesar de una salida precoz en
Roma y hablando precisamente Roma Pues
el rey allí Esta vez fue Danny el ruso
quien consiguió su primer título en
tierra batida y que llega aquí a París
con muchísima más confianza en una
superficie que por lo general no le
agrada mucho hay otros por supuesto
pretendientes como estefanocisipas un
poco pretendientes de siempre también
Casper Ruth finalista del año pasado así
como holger quien también ha venido
haciendo una buena temporada por el lado
de las mujeres va a tratar de defender
su título conseguido aquí el año pasado
pero bueno la polaca no ha tenido tan
buenos resultados como el año pasado no
se le ve tan invencible como parecía
hacerlo en dos mil veintiuno tendrá a
azaba en calle arriba quina como dos de
las más fuertes
contendientes para este para Este título
aquí Así que veremos qué pasa en todo
caso un Roland garros bastante abierto y
por supuesto los franceses que esperan
conseguir por fin un nuevo título
justamente cuando se están celebrando
los cuarenta años del título de El único
francés hombre en haber conseguido un
título aquí en París